hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone at the
South by Southwest Film first of all by
the fire toast those hands with John
Kriss director and star of a quiet place
[Applause]
[Music]
the premise says it was pitched to me
right at the beginning was it's about a
family that can't make any noise and you
have to figure out why and I thought
that's one of the best one-liners I've
ever heard when I was pitched it I
instantly knew he was on to something it
seemed like a concept I was like I was
nobody done this before they haven't
done it before we're gonna do it
very terrifying you know I'd done all
those scenes and I was like yeah this is
gonna be fine I'm I'm not scared I never
know what's gonna happen I was jumping
out my seat literally we have a deaf
character in the movie who played who's
our daughter
it was absolutely non-negotiable that we
had a deaf actress play that role not
only because obviously it would be of
much more fully realized performance but
also because I would have a guide
through this entire thing he was very
open teaching them the lines in American
Sign Language he was effect quite picked
it up really quickly so did Noah I mean
no I knew a little bit of science before
we started filming but it was a lot of
fun it made everything fun because I
could communicate with everybody it was
really nice her disability ultimately
you know becomes the power you know and
I think that that is exciting to play
with that our favorite film is jaws and
we've seen it it's just an embarrassing
number of times yes of course it's
suspenseful it's utterly terrifying but
it truly is a character story about
these three men all having to overcome
some kind of fear because I wasn't as
schooled in the world of horror as I
should have been i weirdly was a good
buffer for how far I could push an
audience cuz I couldn't take much more I
had a threshold that I couldn't go past
he was always asking us what do you
think about the city what do you think
we need to do now
including us all in and it felt like we
were making it together and then there
was a really good team you know
what was it like having John behind the
lens or on set with you amazing and we
were so aligned in what we felt about
the film we don't have that sort of
diplomacy that wastes so much time in
some ways by trying to be polite I'd be
like that doesn't work and he and he'd
be like I see what you're doing it's not
working and I was like okay I mean the
first big scene we did was this very
emotional scene and one take is all it
was and it's like the the air change in
the room she's as good as I've ever seen
and and I was just completely and
totally moved I'm I'm now even more a
fan of hers
you